river run
past eve and adams from swerve of shore
to bend of bay brings us by a commodious
vikus of recirculation
back to howath castle and environs
sir tristrum the elordo morsev or the
short sea
had passing corps re-arrived from north
america
on this side the scraggi isthmus of
europe
minor to welter fight his penicillin
war nor had top sawyers rocks by the
stream orcone
exaggerated themselves to lawrence
county gorgios
while they went dublin their mumber all
the time nor
a voice from a fire bellowed misha
misha to tarte tough dark patrick
not yet though venice soon after had a
kid scab
butt ended a bland old isaac not yet
the walls fair in fantasy were sophie
cester's roth
with two in one nathan joe rotapek
of paw's malt had gem or shen
brewed by arclight and roary
end to the reagan bow was to be seen
ringsome on the aquaface
the fall baba
ba dal garagata
of a once wall straight old par
is retailed early in bed and later on
life do it down through all
christian minstrel see the great fall of
off wall entailed at such short notice
the fit shoot of finnegan earth's
solid man that the humpty hill head of
himself
promptly sends an uninquiring one well
to the west in quest of his humpty
dumptoes
and their up turnpike toe and place
is at the knockout in the park where
oranges have been laid to rest upon the
green
since devlin's first loved livy
big mr finnegan of the stuttering hand
freeman's mower lived in the broadest
way imaginable
in his rush lit too far back for
messages before joshua and
judges had given us numbers or
helviticus
commuted deuteronomy one yeasty day
he sternly strucks his teat in a tall
before to wash the future of his fates
but arie swiftly took it out again by
the might of moses
the very water was eviperated and all
the goodnesses had met
their exodus so that ought to show you
what a pension junction choppy was
and during mighty odd years this man of
hard cement and edifices
hce hot cement and edifices in topper
storp piled build on supra buildup on
the
banks of the livers by the so and so
he iada idle fifi annie
ogged the little creature with her
hiring horns
took up your part in her off-while
fabulous
mirror ahead with goodly trowel and
grasp and
overall overalls which he had
particularly
fancied like harum childrick
edgar birth he would calculate
by multiplicable the altitude and
multitude until he seesaw by neat light
of the liquor where twint was
born his round head stable of other days
to rise in undress masonry
upstanded joy granite
a wall worth of a scare scrape of
most eiffel haleth and towerly
originating from next to nothing and
selecting the hymnals and all
hierarchy tech typo floppical
with a burning bush a bob off its bubble
top
and with lorenzo toolers clittering up
and thomas are buckets cluttering down
now what this paragraph says is he was a
great builder
and i think if you think back through
your impression of hearing it
read you knew that you know these
words that are associated words like
a wall worth of a sky or scrape of most
eiffel houth and towerly
these are skyscraper words woolworth
skyscrape entowerly howath
so forth and so on here's just one
paragraph
from the wake scene which builds and has
quite a minor amount of humor associated
with it
she's i should say
makuul a day
of a trying thursday morning
sobs they sided at philigon's
chrysomorus wake
all the hooligans of the nation
prostrated in their consternation
and their due dismally proflusive
plethora of u-election
there was plums and grooms and sheriffs
and sitters and
raiders and cinnamon too and they all
joined in
with the shoutmost show reality
agog and magog and the round of them a
grog
to the continuation of that celebration
into
hand and hungan's extermination
some in kink and chorus more can
can keenan belling him up and filling
him down
he's stiff but he's steady as priya
molem
twasi was a decent gay labor and youth
sharpen his pillow scone top up his beer
era where in this world will you hear
such a dinnigan with their deep brow
fundings and the dusty fidelios
they laid him brawn drawn a long last
bed with apocalypse a fisky for his feet
and a
barrel load a goodness or his head ti
the total of the fluid hang the twaddle
of the fuddledo
well it's a drunken irish witch and that
seems clear but there are a lot of
things going on
era where in this world will you hear
such a din again
and he's stiff but he's steady is priya
molam
all this all this
dionysian and sexual imagery
is fully explicit
let me read this description of ann
olivia plurabel and then we'll go back
to the synopsis
how beautiful and how true to wife of
her
when strongly forbidden to steal our
historic presence from the past
post-propofols so as to will make us all
lord the heirs and lady madises of a
pretty nice
kettle of fruit she is living in our
midst of
debt and laughing through all plours for
us
her birth is uncontrollable with a
naparon
for her mask and her sabo's kicking
arias
so sare so solly if you ask
me and i suck you how how greeks may
rise and troisters fall
she is mercenary through the length of
the land lies under liquidation
flute and there's nara harbo not an
ibrush
on this globalist place of herschroft
what our vulture shall loan a vesta and
hire some pete
and search the shores her cockles to
heat
and she'll do all a tarf woman can to
puff the business on
path to puff the blaziness on
puff puff and even if humphrey shall
fall from the times as awkward again
in the beard's busaloom of all our grand
remonstrances
there'll be eggs for the breakers come
to mourn him
sunny side up with care so true it is
that there's where's the turnover the
tay is wet
too and when you think you catch sight
of a hind make sure
you're cocked by a hen
well nora felt that jimmy would have
been much
better as a singer she
so stated
[Music]
you